thank you for being brave travel down
the road back again
[Music]
come
the biggest
[Music]
[Applause]
you see the biggest gap would be me
[Music]
thank you for being a friend hey
everybody its charlie
so the dip pool just dropped a Golden
Girls trailer and if you guys didn't
know there are actually a lot of Golden
Girls Easter eggs in the movie
especially the first movie there's a
long-standing tradition of Deadpool
being obsessed with Bea Arthur from The
Golden Girls in the comics that they
then carried forward into the first
Deadpool movie they brought it into
Deadpool 2 but most people missed it if
you don't follow Ryan Reynolds on social
like there were a couple Easter eggs he
revealed before the movie came out that
for whatever reason they didn't call out
in an obvious way like they did in the
first movie so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos we're just
getting started we have a bunch of stuff
coming up this summer too but obviously
the big thing here if you're not a
Golden Girls fan or you don't know
what's going on with Deadpool's
obsession with Bea Arthur the song
that's playing in the trailer thank you
for being a friend is the theme song
from The Golden Girls TV show and all
these titles are done in the same style
as the titles from the golden girl TV
show opening credits in addition you can
also see that for the opening titles
they did this as if it were a TV show in
these characters were playing people in
the TV show so you're like you have
Nathan summers as cable instead of it
saying Josh Brolin is cable you have
Wade Wilson as Deadpool Nina Thurman as
Domino that's Domino's real name in the
comics Colossus is real name is Peter
Rasputin if you guys didn't know he
actually has a sister in the comics
named Illyana Rasputin who's named magic
she's actually a character in the New
Mutants movie that box is doing all of
you are dangerous
that's why you're here now we don't know
if they're gonna connect that to any of
these movies they're doing that is more
of a serious straight-up horror film so
we probably won't find out more about
that till later this year and then they
have the whole Disney Fox kill that's
going on so anything could change with
their relationship down the road
dopinder as dopinder because he doesn't
have a special code name even though
Deadpool does call him brown panther by
the end of the film Peter W just playing
Peter w I love the fact that they never
revealed what the W stands for because
so many people wanted him to be somebody
special before the movie came out like
Peter wisdom in the comics so I will say
you know careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the movie yet just because
it's only been out for a couple weeks
but unless they're trying to pull a fast
one on us into the next movie Peter is
just a totally normal dude that's meant
to humanize Deadpool there's the scene
in the back of the plane where he starts
yelling at him and says no no no don't
worry I'm just doing this for the others
I would never let anything happen to you
which is why Ryan Reynolds justifies
Deadpool's actions at the end of the
film when he goes back to save him he
just says Peter is the only one that he
really cares about on the back of that
plane the whole Bea Arthur thing that I
mentioned before the movie came out was
Ryan Reynolds just saying that his
katanas are named B and Arthur B is a
dedicated performer and a joy to work
with
Arthur is grumpy bumpy so they didn't
specifically call that out during the
film the way they did during the first
film like when you see him at the
beginning where he's wearing the Bea
Arthur T shirt they didn't have any
really obvious Easter eggs like that but
during the early to mid-2000s Bea Arthur
would pop up on a pretty regular basis
in the Deadpool titles thanks to Fabian
dissuasive would write her in it really
started right at the beginning of
Deadpool and cable-like in that first
issue he's watching TV in bed and
suddenly the image changes from Halle
Berry to beat Arthur this sort of big at
the be Arthur obsession and the way they
explained it later on after she'd popped
up a couple times in the comics was that
she reminded Deadpool of his mother so
that's kind of why they have blind owl
in the film looking a little bit like
she would fit in with the Golden Girls
you guys may have spotted the outlaw
Easter egg during the Deadpool movie now
she's like a pretty
big recurring character in the Deadpool
comics pretty notable for her appearance
she's a mercenary that walks around
wearing a halter top so she's hard to
miss she's the poster here in the
hallway during the x-force audition
scenes inside sister Margaret's school
for wayward children if you wonder where
they are this room is inside that bar
they have an on-again off-again
relationship in the comics there was a
1-point in the suicide Kings comic book
where he's sitting with her and he's
kind of troubled and he looks at her in
hallucinates Bea Arthur wearing her
t-shirt so it gets pretty meta one of
the better times though is during the
Deadpool Corps comic book the elders of
the universe hire the Deadpool Corps to
go out on a mission in outer space and
they named their ship the Bea Arthur so
they're flying around in outer space in
the Bea Arthur it would be actually
interesting to see Deadpool in the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in outer space and some sort of
adventure maybe in somebody else's title
the director of thor ragnarok expressed
an interest in doing a thor deadpool
crossover funny thing about thor
ragnarok though is that they introduced
Jeff Goldblum's Grandmaster character as
one of the elders of the universe in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but during the
Deadpool Corps comic book when they went
into outer space in the Bea Arthur
spaceship the story was all about
testing their worthiness giving them a
big challenge facing the champion they
stranded him on a planet they teamed up
and defeated an entity that had been
around since the beginning of the
universe so there are ways to use
Deadpool and big cosmic stories as long
as you let them be really meta and
ridiculous so will be a little bit
harder to use more mainstream Marvel
characters but some of the more
ridiculous
Deadpool characters like Galacta pool or
dread pool from Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe who forms an evil
version of the core going around the
multiverse just killing all those
characters all sort of separate entities
that exist by themselves separate from
what you would consider main 6-1-6
cannon so there are ways to do the
really ridiculous stuff but we'll see
where they keep them but there's a whole
bunch of other Golden Girls Easter eggs
that go all the way back to the first
movie if you remember he celebrated the
30th anniversary of Golden Girls they
turned it into a big thing
they even had Betty White review the
film before it came out so they turned
it into a big part of the marketing
hello I just saw the most anticipated
movie of the year
Deadpool it was glorious
once-in-a-generation a movie comes along
that your whole family will love if your
family is a put-up group of guessing
inbreds Plus Ryan Reynolds look so can
you handsome in his red leather suit I
give it for Golden Girls it's the best
picture of the year so go see Deadpool
this Friday we'll have to wait and see
when they released the extended cut of
the film on blu-ray later this year if
they cut any other big Easter eggs but
usually that stuff winds up being really
dirty jokes and just stuff that was too
crazy to actually put in the movie or
stuff that Fox forced them to take out
or if it got banned in some country so
what'll happen is is I have more Marvel
and DC to post this weekend there's some
new Rick and Morty season 4 that I'll
post next click here to learn about all
the Deadpool deleted scenes and banned
jokes and click here to learn all about
the official synopsis for Avengers 4
thank you so much for being a friend and
everybody stay awesome
we'll see you